[Musique]
bon appétit de quoi non je disais bon
appétit ouais vu que tu manges et tout
tu me crois folle ah non pas du tout tu
l'écris constamment de quoi tu le penses
constamment
elle a une couleur ma présence ah ça
ouais donc c'est pas une odeur inhumaine
et sordide ah ouais quand même
je viens à Saint-Laurent ce soir et j'ai
fait une bêtise absolue c'est que ils
m'ont interdit de porter une chemise
normalement j'étais torse nu sur la
chemise moi je trouve ça affreux et je
trouve ça très plouc de torse un costume
et on leur a dit oui et en fait j'étais
pris de panique et je me suis dit
il fait une chemise donc j'ai pris la
chemise qui est mon manager je sais pas
d'où ça vient et alors je porte des
bijoux bulgaris qui sont des grands
copains
c'est alors tu verras pas c'est génial
faut le faire voilà c'est aux angles
c'est la luge qui descend de on est où
là on est à combien là 2002 et on
descend à 16 en lu c'est formidable pour
ceux qui ont trop bu prenez la luge
elles vont ramener en ville voilà